[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti bello tornare in
questo teatro ci sono stato poco tempo
fa con un grande musical del Sistina mi
pare Tutti insieme appassionatamente
Allora io oggi
vorrei fare con voi una riflessione
partendo naturalmente da quello che è
un elemento che per me nella vita è
sempre stato molto importante che è il
mare le tempeste
Pensate un Onda Anomala può raggiungere
l'altezza di 30 metri praticamente un
palazzo di 10 piani
nel 1958 in Alaska nella Baia di
Lituania Si è scatenata un'onda Anomala
pensate di
526 metri praticamente
l'Empire State Building
c'è da dire però che quando la vita ci
si mette
Quando si mette di traverso non è da
meno
ho vissuto come attore qualche anno fa
una tempesta importante
voi dovete sapere noi
ci Formiamo Io mi sono formato da
bambino nei grandi sceneggiati
televisivi ho cominciato così poi il
doppiaggio perché gli sceneggiati
televisivi all'epoca dovete sapere Non
era carino
apparire in TV seri un bimbo era un
problema Chiaramente io i miei fratelli
lo facevamo per dare una mano No perché
a casa nostra mamma e papà non erano
attori famosi quindi si dava una mano
però era disdicevole quindi mio papà mi
tolse
dagli sceneggiati televisivi e cominciai
a fare il doppiaggio piano piano un po'
alla volta noi attori artisti
ci confezioniamo una sorta di zainetto
chiamiamolo così
dove mettiamo un po' alla volta nel
tempo
tutte le nostre esperienze
riuscite non riuscite e ogni volta una
tacca viene aggiunta in questo zainetto
e piano piano andiamo avanti andiamo
avanti e si arricchisce sempre di più
questo zaino
lo zaino cos'è
è il curriculum
di una persona
tant'è che ogni tanto aprendo lo
zainetto
Vai a rileggere No quello che c'è dentro
e mano mano che passano gli anni passa
il tempo
rileggendo quei titoli quelle esperienze
a prendere un po' di consapevolezza No
Il nostro è un mestiere molto aleatorio
Noi siamo sindacabili io posso piacere
alle signore qui in prima fila
dall'altra parte magari no Quindi non è
così semplice però quel curriculum ogni
volta che lo prendiamo e lo guardiamo
ci dà una sorta di sicurezza No noi
nasciamo precari gli attori sono sono
precari sempre
e avere
questo
compagno di viaggio che mano a mano si
arricchisce Per noi è fondamentale
tant'è che quando veniamo chiamati a un
provino magari per uno spettacolo
teatrale da fare in un teatro o uno
sceneggiato televisivo un film La prima
cosa che ti chiedevano era il curriculum
ed era ogni volta che ti arrivava questa
richiesta era un momento
particolarissimo per almeno per me
andare a riprendere il curriculum Ma
leggerlo e dire bene vai Insomma c'è
tanto qua dentro c'è proprio tanto vabbè
Mandiamolo
parecchi anni fa diciamo intorno forse
sette sei Non mi ricordo una mattina mi
chiama il mio agente Claudio Renda
e mi dice Senti Luca
ci devi preparare un attimo i tuoi
insight
i dati interni dei tuoi Social
e che sono i dati interni dei social io
non ho sempre avuti i social Sono stato
uno dei primi ma però non sapevo cosa
fossero questi dati interni cosa sono tu
vai ho dovuto pure chiedere dico Scusate
Come si vedono i dati interni vai a
vedere all'interno e c'hai un po' di hai
un po' di informazioni
il pubblico
pubblico maschile femminile
l'età
tutta una serie di dati quanti ti
mettono mi piace quanti non te lo
mettono Insomma va bene e prendo tutti
questi dati
e poi una volta raccolti dico Scusa però
a che servono no perché siccome deve
t'hanno chiesto per un film allora
vogliono avere questi dati Vabbè lì per
lì non ci ho pensato più di tanto e li
ho inviati Bram
dopo qualche tempo mi arriva un'altra
richiesta di questo tipo e poi un'altra
e poi un'altra
Allora la domanda
mi è venuta Come si dice spontanea
ma il curriculum
che fine ha fatto
Allora ho chiesto
ho detto Scusate Abbiate pazienza ma
perché Ci chiedete i dati dei social e
non il nostro storico
cioè quella quella cosetta carina che
parla di noi
racconta di noi artisti di quanto
abbiamo corso camminato percorso strada
magari abbiamo fatto cose belle e meno
belle non tutte le ciambelle riescono
col buco ma perché non ce lo chiedete
più
è veramente per anni Quella quella quel
foglio quelle quelle pagine sono rimaste
ferme la
Oggi ti chiedono
quanti follower hai
Credetemi Io adoro i social e sono un
grande comunicatore sui social mi piace
molto comunicare con le persone ma che
ci azzecca
Che vuol dire
un artista come fa a dimostrare
la sua capacità recitativa
con i follower
siamo sicuri Io spero che non accada
anche per i medici perché allora è un
problema
[Musica]
[Applauso]
il pomeriggio ero a casa
arriva mio figlio lupo quindici anni con
il telefonino in mano
e mi fa vedere dice papà questo
doppiaggio è un cartone animato però
sento qualcosa di strano
voi sentire anche tu
Fammi sentire
che noti
ma dico guarda quello che parla di più
Non mi sembra proprio un professionista
mi sembra uno un po' boh
è un po' aggrappato alla parete No dice
Ma lo sai chi è dico no Non lo so è un
tiktoker
ah Che cos'è un tik toker e Tik Tok papà
Ah ho capito ok Ti tocca Quindi Beh
pensa che questo qua è stato chiamato a
doppiare il protagonista di questo film
perché ha più di 2 milioni e mezzo di
follower non è un attore Non ha mai
doppiato in vita sua ma gli hanno fatto
fare questo protagonista E cosa ancora
più incredibile papà gli hanno dato
quello che tu non prendi in 50 film
Allora ho detto lupo Sì ma dove vuoi
arrivare beh papà che insegnamento passa
io ti vedo studiare tutti i giorni tu
hai fatto un percorso questo no Allora
io che devo fare quando tu mi dici no
Devi studiare lupo studio importante la
scuola ma dove sto andando Mi faccio
pure io un profilo su Tik Tok me compro
un po' di follower e poi forse mi
chiamano pure a me a fare il doppiaggio
di un grande film
capite che come padre non più come
artista ti senti come dire un po' in
imbarazzo
ma soprattutto come artista Io vorrei
capire e non l'ho mai capito nessuno me
l'ha mai spiegato a chi è venuto in
mente Qual è stato Quel genio che una
mattina si è svegliato nel suo mega
ufficio con il suo mega stipendio e ha
detto No no via il curriculum vediamo
che ci ha più follower
Nessuno mi ha mai saputo rispondere
pensate fate un film tempo fa Quinto
nome io eh Quinto nome quindi c'erano 1
2 3 4 prima di me belli no importanti
molto molto più importanti di me e mi
dicono dalla produzione Guarda No
abbiamo deciso la promozione per il film
La affidiamo solo a te
Addio Scusate ma no perché io sono il
quinto nome non deve essere su di me ci
sono i miei attori I miei compagni che
sono molto più importanti di me sì hai
ragione ma vai a vedere i loro profili
non hanno follower
cioè capite che è imbarazzante
soprattutto per noi che solchiamo questi
palcoscenici qui
quante volte io mi ricordo da bambino
quando ho cominciato a fare teatro Ero
terrorizzato magari avevo due battute
perché si comincia proprio da zero e poi
piano piano nel tempo
premesso Ah io non ho mai fatto un
accademia
quindi a volte quando sento i miei
colleghi E dice no io vengo
dall'accademia d'arte drammatica Silvio
D'Amico Io sto zitto perché ho
cominciato da bambino Però hai fatto
tutto un percorso
pazzesco incredibile e allora così ci
stiamo andando a schiantare contro il
nulla
i miei colleghi mi dicono Vabbè a Luca e
dai e guarda il bicchiere mezzo pieno
che poi io vorrei che picchi l'ha
inventata sta cosa del bicchiere mezzo
pieno
Ma che vuol dire E no devi vedere la
parte piena
E ho capito ma se andiamo avanti così se
svuota del tutto
le competenze
non servono più non ha più senso io
continuo ad averlo il mio curriculum e
ogni volta lo aggiorno
nella speranza che poi il nostro settore
possa fare
macchine indietro
e ritornare alle competenze Perché anche
qui ce n'è tanta di competenza qualcuno
si ricorderà no gli attori del
dopoguerra Cioè ci avevamo un esercito
di grande cinema italiano non è stato
fatto Certo con i follower Ma è stato
fatto con le competenze e quindi io me
lo tengo lì nel mio zainetto con la
speranza che un giorno qualcuno mi dica
Guarda che vogliono leggere un tuo
curriculum Ecco questo per me sarebbe il
regalo più bello ma soprattutto pensando
ai giovani ai ragazzi
per loro Noi ormai abbiamo fatto
abbiamo fatto tanto
però loro dovevano come gli spieghi a un
giovane ragazzo che vuole fare teatro No
guarda devi metterti dentro un'accademia
per anni ti devi fare un mazzo così
quando poi arriva il tiktoker passa
avanti
bisogna riflettere su questo
noi che siamo più grandi cercare di fare
delle barriere e soprattutto
dare un po' di speranza questi ragazzi
perché altrimenti è un disastro questo
all'estero vi posso assicurare in alcuni
paesi Inghilterra Francia Spagna senza
andare negli Stati Uniti non succede Non
ti chiedono quanti follower hai ancora
lì chiedono i curriculum
Io mi auguro che le cose cambino per
tutti quanti noi e soprattutto per il
nostro paese che torni ad essere
il paese che faceva il grande cinema Il
grande teatro e la grande televisione
come giusto che sia Grazie
[Applauso]